foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
no matter how many minutes
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the riddles podcast in
the Dunya the three Muslims
alhamdulillah we are finally back home
base all three of us
faced on me right now man
oh God that's funny man he doesn't even
know he's alive
okay I'm gonna answer I'm gonna answer
one second
yo you're alive bro we're live right now
[Laughter]
chats BMW okay he's fine we're not on
iPhone where we removed them for now
inshallah he's like finally leveled up
his setup is super clean alhamdulillah
so he's just uh finishing the doing the
finishing touches inshallah um whenever
you you're good to come on let us know
inshallah we can bring you up
also Order in the Court there's a little
bit of tension going on in the in the
chat right now
wait sorry what was that on him I said
there's a little bit of a tension in the
chat right now because somebody's name
is Islamic I don't know if I should say
this because it might get us
D platformed but people are beefing over
someone's username guys come on be
respectful
it's okay it's okay in short life if you
can't if you can't make this one because
of it no worries
Rami how's the audio
I'm talking on her right now
we back baby after three weeks
of being on YouTube jail I'm now back
okay
this new app I gotta go and the new mug
got the new setup
all right yeah something I apologize
guys forgive me for that don't beep over
usernames everyone chill relax in the
chat yeah we're going to be disagreeing
with people but we're going to be
inshallah very respectful about it um as
per usual
so with that being said
um I think we should just jump into it
you know this is technically not the
first stream with all three of us back
so let's let's just jump into it let's
let's instill A Little Bit Of taqwa in
in the hearts and minds of the of the
viewers right now so in a nutshell how
did rasulu deal with the enemies of
Islam was he kind of arrogant Petty and
you know just low energy or did he have
a lot of professionalism and other
process had the best of character and he
dealt with every individual accordingly
according to what they needed
alhamdulillah inshallah we will do the
same the process was always kind and
soft until given a reason to be harsh
and even in you know his Dao if he was
being insulted or anything he never
really you know he never insulted back
didn't even really defend himself for
anything he just sat there quietly
to the best of my knowledge so inshallah
for us as Muslims we want to be good
representatives for people and for
Muslims that may watch
we want to deal with this in an
appropriate manner we want to deal with
it intellectually academically so
inshallah we're going to limit any
insults regardless of how we feel about
people because let's be like let's be
honest we're not friendly with any of
these guys well I don't say any of them
but you know there are two identifiable
people who are definitely not friendly
with but that doesn't mean we have to go
and insult people so inshallah we're
gonna address them respectfully and
address their points intellectually
inshallah
with that being said
let's just get into it I will say I'm
gonna be honest this is not meant to be
rude I'm just being blunt a lot of the
time they're just joking around saying
nonsensical stuff it was kind of sad to
be honest not so much on John's part but
more so on
the part of these two here so
I only have certain what is the context
of this bro before we go in yeah so long
story short it's a great question I
should have started with that snickle
made a video or a few several streams
talking about why he accepted this time
he discussed it with us and then John
who is the brother on the right here is
a Christian responded to some of
sneako's claims and was trying to argue
that he should actually be a Christian
based on what he's saying and then
um red Von and David wood jumped on a
stream with him and just Honestly made
very sad arguments I didn't watch the
whole thing I skipped through it and
have a few time stamps so inshallah this
is not to agree with one person or the
other it's to dispel misconceptions and
spread what Islam actually is and
explain why we know with all due respect
Christianity is not the truth sent by
God and why and how we know Jesus peace
and blessings be upon him although he's
a mighty prophet and messenger and
Messiah of Allah he is not God himself
um
so that being said inshallah let's just
get right into it
so I got the first time right here
let's start with his first reason okay I
resonate with Islam why it makes sense
for me because it's we
do and that we should pray to should be
the one creator of the universe which is
wait what do you say did he say the only
man we should submit to hang on I want
to see that or is it going to be lagging
reject Islam and instead become a
Christian so don't believe me
I'll prove it let's start with his first
reason okay why I resonate with Islam
why it makes sense for me because it's
weird it doesn't make sense to me to
pray to a man I don't want to submit to
a man the only person that we should
submit to and that we should pray to
should be the one creator of the
universe which is Allah you create a
universe and we love him for it wait
what did you say why I resonate with
Islam why it makes sense for me because
it's weird it doesn't make sense to me
pray to a man
meant to a man the only person that we
should submit to the person should pray
to should be the one creator of the
universe which is Allah Ukrainian
universe and we love him for it perfect
that really it makes the most sense to
me so as she's just heard snico doesn't
like the idea of submitting to a man and
therefore decided to reject Christianity
and to embrace Islam but unfortunately
there are a lot of reasons there are a
lot of that wasn't the reason that I
referred it to Islam but that's the
reason why Christianity never resonated
with me really snico really does have a
yeah
people are asking him why he converted
he gives the reasons then we say hey
yeah
well that's not the reason
he will keep doing that again and again
but he just doesn't understand
John starts counting the reasons and he
mentions one reason he's like well
that's not the only reason there are
more reasons yeah see this is what I
mean like I'm sorry it's such uh
incredulous and sad argument to make
like if someone asks you why you're a
Muslim and you give a reason right you
give a reason
that doesn't mean that's the only reason
that may be in the more powerful reason
I think it's funny that ridwan has
mentioning this because he kind of was
you know jumped in a debate with
Muhammad ajab if you guys remember he
was on a podcast with like Adam Saleh
and then Mohammed a job jumped in and
Muhammad asked him what's your strongest
argument against the stem and he
produced with all due respect the worst
possible arguments literally they were
like scientific inaccuracies and then
some kind of uh moral argument which is
very sad for atheists to make to be
completely honest we can talk about that
inshallah towards the industry and then
he got completely refuted in those and
you guys can watch it it's online so
does that mean that he should delete his
channel because his one reason that he
doesn't believe in Islam was completely
decimated on the spot I don't think he
would agree with that same so why are
you playing this game honestly it's so
sad
for um you know for someone to make this
this argument especially being online as
long as he has like is this the level of
augmentation that you can bring
especially someone who just accepted
Islam
bro of the best intellectual contention
they have is why sneako said a man
shouldn't be who we submit to but then
said The only person
I think we're looking pretty good right
now bro
but let's uh let's continue
yeah
that's an ongoing problem is John will
start responding to something and I'll
go but there's this other stuff and then
like John's about to respond to the
other stuff it's this ongoing thing
where he flips out like like so notice
it's like if you if you say if you if
you have three if you have three things
you want to respond to them about you
know something he said then as soon as
you start responding to one he starts
going ow but what about this other it's
like what if you have the slightest bit
of patience here buddy just a slight bit
three is one anyways all right here we
go you know so I can submit into a man
then he should reject Islam the reason
why is because according to the Quran
sneako has actually commanded to submit
to Muhammad who's a man so if this is a
real reason God
uh
it's I mean it's again just such sad
levels of argumentation I don't know if
I should make us big or keep on the show
I'll just keep it the way it is for now
but
now let's listen if we talk let's let's
do this okay inshallah I'll let you Olay
handle it then
so
oh that type I feel like that looks
weird
you think so I hear I'll just there boom
all right now so listen
there are certain premises that you have
to infer when listening to some people
speak for example sunico said that he
doesn't want to submit to a man there's
a certain inference that you have to
make which is that you should not submit
to a man generally
or explicitly
as soon as you submit to a man over God
over Allah you've submitted to someone
who is biased
let me get in the camera someone who's
biased someone who doesn't know
everything someone who will definitely
be incorrect definitely be incorrect and
this is the issue with submitting to any
man with any group of men any group of
people this is the problem with
liberalism as well they make the human
being Sovereign even though they have
biases and limited knowledge and so on
and so forth
so what's really just a fallacious
argument to say well you submit to
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
why do we obey the prophet
because Allah Almighty gave him the
knowledge of Islam perfect wisdom of
Islam and commanded us to listen to him
in his judgment on the religion
that's why it's such a simple logical
deduction that any I know they I know
they understand this this is the thing
and David would know this they just
don't care they're looking for any
gotcha moment where they could take a
word and twist it now the many times
they mentioned oh this was in context it
wasn't out of context he said this word
for word and listen if you were to take
John 17 3
um for Vadim you would denounce Jesus as
God because it says it says the father
or Jesus speaking of the father so that
they may know you the only true God and
Jesus Christ who you sent
okay what about what Paul said he said
that the father is God and Jesus is Lord
and lordship by the way especially back
then doesn't mean Lord like God it could
just be a master it could be a landlord
could be uh like a slave Lord a
relationship kind of thing
so God is oh father is oh he's God and
then Jesus is under they were
subordinationists to be fair
historically speaking but you can use
the same verbatim argument with things
like that so it's very pathetic that
they're making these these kind of
arguments man honestly someone said
kindergarten arguments literally
literally it's like but you said this
you didn't exactly say that it's like
you're literally missing the tree you're
sorry you're missing the force for the
trees
you're missing the force for the trees
by the way uh that's an excellent point
on Hill message the group chat he said
he's uh he's gonna join some inshallah
that's great alhamdulillah
all right uh I did not we did I didn't
see Bobby's perspective's uh reaction
but uh I don't know if I did watch it no
not yet bro okay Michelle maybe it's
funny we're doing a reaction to our
reaction to our reaction to our reaction
right uh
[Music]
okay well first problem go ahead
yeah that there's there's two there's
two big ones here just with that ah but
we don't pray to him so notice
you he said
I don't believe in praying to a man
or in submitting to a man you point out
that according according to the Quran
you have to submit to Muhammad it's a
requirement Surah 4 verse 65 says you
are not a Muslim unless you submit to
all of Muhammad's decisions you have to
submit to everything Muhammad decides
and then as soon as you point out that
he said he doesn't want to submit to a
man
and
therefore he just contradicted the Quran
because the Quran requires him to submit
to a man he says Ah but we don't we
don't pray to him
so that's the other so so note yeah you
you made two claims he destroyed one and
then you said ah what about the other
one okay I mean you said submit you this
uh this is so sad I mean I think maybe
David wood just is too excited and
didn't hear what sneako said because the
first time he made a mistake he said
first and he thought he said man this
time he made a mistake he said worship
he thought he said uh pray to he didn't
say pray to nobody said he I don't even
think he said the word pray maybe he did
all he said was we I don't want to
worship a man
I don't want to worship I don't want to
submit to I dealt with the submission
one now he doesn't want to worship a man
we don't worship a man Point Blank
period end of discussion and now the
whole discussion of and this is why I I
actually genuinely believe David wood is
just a willfully ignorant liar and I
don't say that to be rude because if you
go watch the debate between him and
Muhammad hijab Muhammad hijab
may Allah bless them and increase him he
dealt with this on the spot
and I believe it was so traumatizing for
David I don't think he would forget such
an event
he explained it and basically it's as
follows the problem and I'm sorry if
this is boring I'm going to break things
down logically for everyone so people
can see the mistakes right the mistakes
logically with what they're saying the
problem with praying to someone
as you're putting them in place of God
and you're giving them the attributes or
the place that only God has so when you
pray to someone especially someone who's
passed away
what does that mean
that means that you believe that this
person is hearing that they can hear you
from Beyond the graves in in a
metaphysical sense
in a spiritual sense this is shirk this
is this is disbelief you're not allowed
to believe this when we say and this is
what he mentioned earlier in the video
um basically uh peace be upon you o
Prophet we don't believe that the
prophet son can hear us
we don't believe the process someone can
hear us we believe and there's a Hadith
that says the angel or there's an angel
that carries it to him and goes and
tells him
so the problem is that we would have to
believe the president can hear and that
he's all hearing or that he's worthy of
Praise like Allah we're saying may Allah
send praise upon you and the angels
delivering with him there is no logical
uh problem with that there's only a
logical problem with his articulation of
it so I hope that makes sense I hope
that's clear inshallah and if it's not
fired in the comments please let me know
no it fully makes sense bro I'm gonna
I'm gonna keep watching before I come in
all right because I'm trying to be very
impartial to this yeah
who said that you said that
um and then the other one clear if you
actually made three because he did say
worship but I addressed the worship
question too here in a second so just to
be clear we'll go ahead oh and yeah the
other thing I was focusing on is Muslims
do they would say they don't pray to
Muhammad but they speak directly to
Muhammad during their prayers there's a
part of their prayers where they say
peace be upon you oh Prophet notice
okay can you do you know what he's
talking about which part yeah yeah
this is
not a conversation between Allah
um I believe that's the origin of it but
his thing what he's saying is that we
are uh saying this while we pray we are
saying while we pray
um
peace be upon you o Prophet Allah and
the mercy of Allah and His blessings
which someone mistranslated to say that
it says may the prayers be upon it
that's not what it says peace
and again we don't believe the process
some can hear us the angel delivers it
to him exactly this is the dangerous
thing
yeah so it's not an issue and on top of
that
on top of that
um there's another Point uh yeah it's
just peace be upon you like a lost piece
so again there's no issue with it I
don't know why he's making such
incredulous arguments but I believe he
is an incredulous person
but uh let's continue inshallah fiber
are you struggling with the thing I'm
trying to figure this out bro that's why
evidence
it's just me and you and we we boot off
the video
you just click remove oh yeah you have
to remove it from the scene okay let me
try that okay we got this
alhamdulillah okay sounds good bro okay
money
person Muhammad they speak directly to
Muhammad so a Muslim praying and a
mosque wherever sneako goes actually
speaks directly to Muhammad that's the
mistake right there that is the fallacy
right there we're not praying for the
process
we're not speaking to him even
we don't believe that he can hear us
we believe the angel carries it to him
so that is the issue that the mistake
that he falls into logically but I mean
actually I'm not going to make a joke I
want to be respectful inshallah so I'm
going to continue
I'm going to skip a little bit because I
kind of covered this stuff already but
anyways go ahead
I want to hear everything directly to
Grandma who's dead in my prayers that's
talking to
that's speaking to someone else in my
prayers and so anyway yeah okay again
makes the false equivalency I debunk
that you guys have anything you want to
add or should we can see this clip well
I want to say uh
verses on the screen too so that's it
but anyways go ahead
okay
um I think he wants to remain in the uh
the whole idea that okay um you
technically do not do not worship or do
not pray to uh Muhammad so you could
just excuse the whole you know sending
blessings prayers and whatever it is
um it is still it is still weird I mean
he doesn't really explain why it is
absurd you know to
um to to worship or to pray to a man
I'm sorry I'm sorry does does Nico
really need to explain why it's wrong to
pray to a man or to worship a man forget
pray because they didn't even say they
said worship does he need to explain why
it's wrong to worship a man
people in the comments even non-muslims
do you need an explanation on why it's
wrong to worship a man
do I need to explain why one plus one
equals two
do I need to explain why I enjoy when
it's sunny out these are basic things
you don't worship a man because they're
not worthy of worship they are a man
just like you so if they were their
worship you should be worthy of worship
as well now if you say oh well they're
Divine or whatever
bring your evidence and even that would
be a contradiction because who was God
all-knowing and if you look at Jesus for
example Jesus was not all knowing he
didn't know the hour all powerful which
is all powerful no he said anything that
I do basically I'm gonna paraphrase but
he says anything that I do is basically
is from the father and without the
father I basically cannot I can't do
anything literally is what he says so
it's very straightforward noise making
such sad arguments there between why it
is then okay to Simply submit to a man
without praying to him or without
worship again so we don't even have the
logic of why it is so you know you don't
need the logic so uh he has to he has to
explain that first but that's the whole
problem with uh with with all of his uh
reasons he never actually explains the
logic behind why the Islamic theology
makes more sense to him why uh you know
worshiping only the Islamic sense of God
and not the Christian sons of God makes
more sense to him he doesn't explain any
of these things he just says it makes
sense to me I feel like this is good but
that's it why does he need to do more
than that why let me ask you that
question why does it need to do more
than that for you he's not an academic
he's not a debater he just started
practicing Islam
why does he need to explain it to you
and maybe he understands it better he
can then he can articulate it
why is this a problem for you and also
why does it need to explain why one God
is simpler and makes more sense than a
three in one God who is who's man and
Son of God and God himself and is ever
living but was born and died and was
born to the woman that he created and
then killed by his own creation
versus worshiping one God Alone
who's not a human being why does he need
to explain that for you
and I'm sorry one last thing I think
it's so funny it's a funny day when the
Christians pair up with the atheists to
like go against the superpower that is
Islam oh 100 bro 100 it's also pure
fitra bro just to realize that there
must be one all-powerful being which is
why even in Christianity amongst
themselves a lot of them don't see it
this way but many of them admit it
subconsciously that the father is still
the all-powerful one over the other two
in the Trinity yeah this is why young
Don abandoned the Trinity hmm
and this is why Islam is beautiful
subhanallah because we say to have a
direct connection to Allah skip all the
intermediaries none of this no
worshiping
none of this I don't know where you know
obviously these are mistransations and
these are poor arguments and many of
them have been refuted too I watched
David one video like two days ago and
and you'll never believe it bro like the
way that again it takes it takes a train
die to see this stuff but with a lot of
experience it's very easy to notice that
when David wood speaks
it's all for the money bro it's all for
the money because you could see it in
his eyes bro you you know when like
someone's lying straight to your face
you could see it in their eyes
when when David wood speaks I've seen so
much of the same arguments that he made
that again shake with man or other
YouTubers or other dies or imams have
either in a debate like Muhammad Oxford
right but when you were talking about or
face to face or even on a stream he's
been refuted to his face but then he'll
blatantly use the same arguments time
and time and again so this either shows
you number one he's either forgetful or
number two he just he doesn't care that
he's being arrogant and he just needs to
keep spreading misguidance because he
gets some money yeah 100 and I encourage
everyone in here the 572 people in here
right now may Allah bless you and sha
Allah and guide you all and guide us as
well like the Stream
584 people now like the stream and go
check out the debates that David wood
did with with Muhammad hijab with
sheikhothman go watch the debates and
decide for yourself you will see very
clearly very very see for yourself we're
not telling you what to do yeah
no I am telling what to do go watch the
debate inshallah do your own research
I'm just I'm just playing I'm just
playing okay let's get back to inshallah
I might I might skip because it's kind
of the same thing yeah I don't want to
take too long uh 33 minutes is the next
one
here we go
and this um questionable things are you
against grooming yeah it's gross how do
you feel about like the fact that
Muhammad like married a nine-year-old
girl um I don't know how true that is
but I don't think any Muslims deny it if
that's true then he's not been you know
nobody's perfect so if snakeo doesn't
have a problem with submitting to a man
like Muhammad who even according to him
wasn't morally perfect then why would he
have a that was before I reverted to
Islam she's asking me questions that I
didn't know the answer to I was saying
that I was thinking about Islam this is
before and I I understand now that
a lot of the time the parents have
better decision-making abilities than
the woman and it was a different time
and Muhammad peaceful was definitely not
a pedophile he had many wives a lot of
them were older than him I think his
first wife was 50 when he was 25 and he
was friends with uh Aisha peace be upon
her he was friends with her parents so I
I don't think that that's an example of
pedophilia Now problem submitting uh I
don't think
I think it doesn't matter what you think
it doesn't matter okay let me let's keep
that in mind for the end of the stream I
have a very special clip I want to show
about him towards the end inshallah
because apparently when it comes to
moral issues it doesn't matter what you
think
and you have to state things with 100 to
Surety and 100 confidence that this is
objective
and with that logic work in any other
situation so he wasn't a putter because
he had older wives too with that I mean
I think about even in court or something
like that right if somebody says oh I
mean sir I mean I'm not a and plus by
the way in the clip the the girl was um
talking about him grooming her too by
the way so he he was responding to the
Muslim responses that they use for that
claim but there it wasn't even about him
that she didn't even say he was a Pedro
and said she said that he was grooming
Aisha which I mean obviously he was okay
pause what did John just say obviously
he was bring your evidence John bring
your evidence let me get the definition
for you right now
the definition I'll have to prove I'm
not a robot first okay
uh you killed me bro am I bad man I
missed you man
hi baby I'm likewise my man all right
the definition
here rain let me go to an official
website rain here
no I don't want a hotline brought down
definition
no way these grown men are serious bro
okay basically
it's the process
of coercing
or deceiving or manipulating someone to
accept any kind of a b u s e okay don't
want to say and get demonetized right
and forcing them to be basically with
you that's what it is
that's what grooming is show me where
the processant did that show me bring
the full context and show me where he
did that
and show me where anywhere in Islam it
advocates for
child marriage or immature marriage
anywhere
because the age of maturity
is not the age of
consent in the west whatsoever
at all yeah now I want to do I want to
deal with this this more head on because
Nico made good points but they didn't
address it they did not address it and
later on I'm not going to play it
because honestly it's always just give
definitions and appeal to fallacy of
presentism and all this garbage
but frankly if you're going to look at a
society in the past you have to look at
everything and how they lived
getting your daughter married
was not just like how it is today oh I
love him so much I want to marry him no
it's a means of protection it is a means
of protection because if the father
passes away they know that their
daughter will be taken care of so it's
not all you know about like oh I'm
physically attracted to you like it is
nowadays there are many multiplications
for marriage back then also for
literally basically all of history
except for the last few hundred years in
the West
when a person hit puberty they were
basically ready for marriage
that has been the standard
and the only reason it changed the only
reason it changes because in the West
in the west Western societies liberal
societies abuse children I said the word
I'm demonetized now boom
Western societies
abuse children and that's why they had
to enforce laws against their own people
to protect children you didn't have this
in Islam
you didn't have this in Islam you had
the protection the protection of them
and this is all being done under the
presence and the authority of her father
who was best friends with the process
even mentioned
so why is this the fallacy of presentism
one more time the reason is the fallacy
of presentation is because if they lived
especially red Von with his subjective
morality they lived at that time they
would be doing the same thing they have
literally no problem with it literally
no problem with it
tell me this bro
not already engaged
she was actually she was this is proven
and like this in and of itself proves
that this was not something weird at the
time this was not something out of place
for that present time this was not a
fallacy
yeah yeah and let me make it even more
clear for you people
when you think of a nine-year-old you
think of an annual today
right now I'm not just talking about
like like how they look what I'm talking
about they are mentally like they're
iPad kids they are iPad kids they don't
know anything compare that to people who
grew up in a society that Not only was
it scorching hot desert but it was
hunting and Gathering young boys are
going to war and fighting Tribal wars
and battles at the age of 13 getting
married at 13 having kids at Young what
we would consult consider young
teenagers
now if I were to do that as a young teen
you everyone think it's weird because it
is weird today we don't do that today
back then it was completely normal fine
there's nothing wrong with it and
there's societal implications that call
for it
societalimplications.com so that's why
it's the fallacy of presentation now I
wanna I wanna take this to um
I don't want to say divert the
conversation but go deeper into it and
I'll talk about the Bible for a second
I want to talk about the Bible because
do you mind if I had a point before you
jump into the next point of the Bible
see when you bro when you look at at
that time too compare the life
expectancy to today so you're saying
that men would mature you know faster
and it was by necessity it wasn't like
they just chose to right today the world
has become very soft just look around
you back then men and women both
developed and matured much quicker at a
faster and efficient Pace into maturity
into puberty than today this is why when
you look at a lot of women they had kids
younger most women would be mothers a
lot of women would be mothers before
women even have marriage or even
Intimacy in today's West and for the
cafers you know outside of marriage
there's like 14 15 year olds 16 year
olds having intercourse bro this is this
is reality because we grew up in the
west we know we know what happens in
school bro but back then it was
commonplace for marriage and motherhood
well before that many times if the woman
qualifies for intercourse through
marriage by the conditions that Islam
places such as mental maturity physical
maturity so on and so forth there was no
child marriage or immature marriage or
the p word or grooming or any of this
yeah 100 and to bring it
that's a great Point that's a great
point and to bring it to um a more kind
of philosophical level or a more logical
level if I were to ask you to prove why
anything is immoral from a subjective
perspective you would not be able to do
so and this is the problem that red one
uh has and we'll see at the end of the
stream inshallah again I have another
clip I'm going to show you guys and
discuss it you can't prove anything is
moral or immoral because it's not
something that's measurable like
empirically yeah you can't like put it
on a Bunsen burner or put it on under a
microscope and and see how moral or
immoral it is it doesn't make any sense
so you need something objective to at
least begin with to have any moral
objective morals other than that
subjective
the way we are living right now
and mark my words the way we are living
right now in 50 years will be considered
immoral
okay in 50 years it's going to be
immoral to live the way we're living
right now with some beliefs that people
have just normal average Americans
just like 20 30 years ago before the
lgtv movement even let's go back even a
little bit further than that
what beliefs did they have about that
community and those people they were
completely immoral did they think they
were immoral no now we do in 50 years
they're going to look back on us say oh
they were completely immoral 50 years
ago
that's what subjective relative morality
is
and there's no fundamental basis for it
but now I want to take it back to John
because we're not just sitting here on
the fence to defend ourselves
we also want to take the offensive
so let me pull this up inshaallah so
John and John is respectful John has
been a respectful person I just would
like for him to bring more evidence
throwing some verses on the screen is
not evidence and if you're going to make
such an egregious claim like that about
grooming about our beloved Prophet peace
and blessing be upon him you need to
bring your evidence and I I would love
to have a discussion or a debate
whatever he'd like to do
um on his own time insha Allah but look
at this verse
so actually let me go to the verse
before for context
it says now off all the boys and off
every woman who has slept with a man
this is the Bible numbers 31 18. but
save for yourselves
every girl
who has never slept with amen now people
might say well it doesn't say children
doesn't say child you don't know their
age okay let's look at the Hebrew
let's do that and bro once you're done
pin up the comment that April's put in
the chat
okay one second
let's go to the Hebrew
but all the young women who have not
known intimately a man keep alive for
yourselves what what's what's this word
what's this word
but all the young women what is this
look
other times it's used in the Bible the
girls children children the little ones
the little ones the little the little
ones and all the little ones the little
the children's children the children so
very clearly
unequivocally the verse to talk about
children and saying say for yourselves
murder everybody else save yourself the
young girls the children
so this John is in your Bible this is in
your books numbers 31 18. do you affirm
God the Father the Son the Holy Spirit
sending this down is revelation
and are you okay with this
Now where's I let me see his comment
okay well first I see a Super Chat the
Hadith uh Aisha was six slash nine were
created the financials character and
exaggerated Purity in response to share
defamation is not an issue of culture no
that's not true with all due respect my
brother this is not true the Hadith was
narrated
herself it was verified by bukhari and
other Scholars with a valid chain of
narration for you to say was made up you
would have to say that one of these
narrators in the chain were completely
lying and the others were dumb enough to
believe her even though they should know
they should know Aisha wasn't nine
that doesn't make any sense so with all
due respect that argument does not uh
follow
actually can you put up this guy I can't
find it
I will try bro first you must teach me
how to access the comment chat on this
new platform my friend you just click
comments it's beside layers and music
let's see
there's where do you see lyrics this is
back to dashboard oh no no no
there we go
bro okay um red Von can you just make
the comment again I can't find it I read
one bro
come through
um okay here we go uh you're twisting
what I said there I'm not making a moral
judgment the it doesn't matter what you
think refers to the definition of well
there's I mean there's one definition
okay that's fair if you want to claim
the arguments for it but listen uh let's
go with that definition what is what is
the definition of um pedo someone who's
attracted you know
I don't want to use the word to get I
already got the monetize whatever
sexually attracted to uh right what is a
child I want to ask you what is a child
a child I'm not talking about Western
Law I'm talking about the definition of
a child someone who is under the age of
puberty that's what a child is
okay someone who's under the age of
Purity or puberty so after they hit
puberty they're no longer a child so if
you're attracted to them or you're
intimate with them it's not considered
that by the classical definition
what happened now is because of Western
laws abusing young people including
people up to 17 years old
yes Western People liberal people taking
advantage of these young immature people
which by the way a qualification of
someone who needs to be ready for
marriage is emotional and mental
maturity that's a big aspect of it as
well this goes for uh not just marriage
but for like orphans for example when
they're gonna get their uh inheritance
and stuff their parents left behind so
we see this in Islam that a person has
to be physically mentally and
emotionally already but let's just focus
on the the physical one because that's
what everyone is focused on the
classical definition says they have to
be above the age of puberty she was
above the age of puberty therefore it's
not immoral by the classical definition
if you want to impose a new definition
now based on Western Law you have to
prove why that is the standard
and and by the way as soon as you do
that you've basically failed you've
basically uh slipped into a fallacy
clearly a presentation but on top of
that you've refuted yourself because why
are you appealing to a liberal law in
the 21st century to talk about laws or a
way of life 1400 years ago
in 7th Century Arabia
and a few comments I hope that I get to
see it because there are so many
comments here if you commented give me a
second that's and that's the last we
heard of him okay inshallah
no worries let's um I don't want to
divert the stream too much let's get
back to the um
the video
oh shoot I'm not even playing it in my
bad
Bismillah here we go
24 7.
yeah bro it's weird because evmux
doesn't let you you know see people from
here you have to go to the actual stream
exactly because me and you doing it we
just get distracted from the actual
stream sometimes yeah I know I know we
are taking applications brothers and
sisters for mods for this chat I don't
know how we made it to almost 200k
obviously by the permission of Allah
without any moderators professionally so
we are taking requests requests we are
taking applications dmos at the three
Muslims or uh Rami or me and then join
the team
so this is a new time stamp might be a
different topic either don't exactly
remember
even according to your own criteria you
should be submitting to Jesus
is that about right that's it that's
right what did he say
let's see if he gets it but to another
reason that sneako gear is for Recovery
I like the fact that you pray five times
a day in Islam that's you're going to be
more grounded they take prayer more
seriously than any other religion all
right now this is actually a really
strange one because not too long after
he recorded this video he asked for
guidance in this area and he said this I
get I don't have the time to pray five
times a day are you supposed to take all
the steps fully are you supposed to
fully dive into it or can you like
what's the what's wow how dare he have
an ideal and then ask how does he reach
that ideal
very sad the next move so now it's
pretty strange that he cites praying
five times a day is something that he
likes about Islam which uh okay let's
let's uh read the response I don't judge
people for see marriage I think you guys
know what C is in 7th Century I judged
the prophet peace and bless me upon him
as a Timeless example you can lengthily
discusses with me and I will be
completely honest with you we'll respond
tomorrow okay inshallah sounds good
based on this
you know what I think that's fair 100 as
a Timeless example amazing and what did
the religion he brought teach
that there are mainly three criteria for
someone to be ready for marriage and
this is better by the way than any age
is the perfect example because it's
above oh you have to be this old what
what age can you say you have to be 30
years old that's way too old for most
people uh okay three is old enough no
most people are not gonna be ready at
three 17 some are ready some are not so
you cannot give an age which is the
problem that the West falls into so what
how do you get around this first you
have to have someone of authority
of legitimacy
whose logical rational enough to make
that decision for you in case you're not
ready mainly the father who's his job by
the way to protect you and if not the
Imam of the measure and if not then the
Khalifa himself that's what Islam says
even State protection for the person yes
the Khalifa himself if need be okay
and on top of that they have to decide
and have to say are you mentally and
emotionally ready for it 100 and if you
are not then you cannot get married hmm
so so someone like uh redwon would look
at a lot today saying that the age of
consensus is 19 in the country because
of that the age of marriage should be
19. you have genetic genetically
I don't want to say anomalies because
there's something disrespectful but you
will generally have women that just
can't have their Menses until maybe way
later than majority way later than the
age of maturity why because it happens
not everyone is the same so what you
think her being physically and mentally
let's say immature for marriage
just because she's that age you think
it's fair then it's not like who who
decided that there's this one size
fits-all thing timelessness shouldn't
should not be based on something
fallible to presentism looking at
today's laws timelessness should be
based on strict Criterion that we do not
miss out on WE adhere to throughout
centuries the Sharia has not changed
since 1400 years ago there's no Sharia
light Sharia Pro Sharia 2.0 there's none
of this but with Western Law how many
times has the age of majority or age of
maturity changed even in the last two
decades three decades bro
two one decade ago a few years ago
same-sex marriage was not even allowed
legally but now it is and look at what
they're teaching the kids now but 20
years from now nobody would have thought
this would be possible
ten years from now they might be talking
about some other ish bro like marrying
animals or whatever does that mean it's
okay no so isn't it better that we have
this one objective guidebook or morality
that we adhere to isn't that Timeless or
the one that's my question isn't that a
better example for all of humanity
forever instead of having things that
are kind of parameters appropriate for
today's time but might not necessarily
be appropriate 100 years from now or 100
years ago yeah 100 that's an excellent
point that's an excellent point and just
to quickly add or maybe maybe even
reiterate what you've already said
quickly
um even if you know you disagree with it
you don't disagree with it objectively
yeah you don't have to agree with it you
don't have to like it but okay it's a
subjective belief there are you know
many people who agree many people
disagree why is your opinion agree
agreement or disagreement better or
worse than someone else's subjectively
morally it doesn't matter
so okay yeah you criticize it okay you
don't like okay cool that doesn't mean
Islam is false
so you can't use that as an argument to
demonstrate why some is false or why you
know snico is
you know immoral in in accepting Islam
or whatever argument you guys were
making initially and also I want to say
the comments everyone be respectful
listen like I mentioned we're not we're
not friendly with these people but we
don't have to go out of our way and
insult people unnecessarily you know it
does not it literally does not help at
all
but let's uh let's get back to inshallah
it's ironically the same thing that he
thinks that he can't do now I'm not sure
if he realizes that these prayers aren't
prayers that spontaneously come from the
heart instead these prayers are just
memorized sayings in Arabic which is of
course a language that okay so liking
structure means that
it doesn't come right sneaker doesn't
understand but a Snicker just likes a
structure that comes with Rich a lot
that's an example he goes what this
whole stream and it's so sad to see
grown men do this is just like kind of
making fun and mocking like are you are
you a grown adult come on man really
sitting here and walking and like just
think for a second he likes the
structure
he likes the rigidity of it he likes the
respectability of it he likes the
discipline in it and why is John
assuming that these are empty prayers
why are these empty prayers all of a
sudden and we don't feel it from the
heart who says we don't love praying
five times a day
why is this a problem oh he responded
let me maximize my screen one second
okay as I said this is a complex lengthy
talk pick talk to me not and talk to me
not in my place I would I wouldn't argue
that Islam is false for this anyway he's
gone to the stream we'll review okay
inshallah sounds good
um
oh he's saying talk to me not in my
place don't talk on your behalf okay no
worries inshallah I mean I'm going based
off what you said and you're refuting
sneako for accepting Islam and this was
brought up so I'm assuming that this is
a reason why you believe Islam is false
or whatever but okay fine nor is
inshallah do your reveal and uh I'd love
to talk to you why don't we organize
something we'll discuss Insha'Allah
there's no point doing back and forth
bro as as grown men and his whole
channel is dedicated to reasons why
Islam is this or that so why are we not
to assume that
that's a great point I mean
with all due respect you can't really
play this game like oh don't talk my
place I never said that it's like your
whole channel is based on this and these
arguments you made multitude of times
average life expectancy was 20 to 30
then so married at 10 uh your life is
almost half over with um
I I both do and don't like this argument
because um they did have a higher infant
mortality rate to be fair this is the
fair argument it's a good point that
needs to be mentioned because they
definitely did not live as long as we
did generally take an average random
person likely uh they didn't it's like
they didn't lift like 80 or whatever so
by the time you're you know 25 30 when
people get married nowadays that's
literally could be half your life right
there right so I think it's both a good
and bad argument but it's it's I feel
like it's it's putting us on the defense
why are we on the defense why are you
even making this argument to begin with
you you need to demonstrate that your
argument's even valid to begin with
whoever is making the argument
but uh let's continue basically on this
clip here about the prayer it's what's
the issue with it
actually as Muslims it's beautiful
because a prayer praying is an act of
worship and you worship Allah even if
you you don't feel like doing it even if
you don't feel for some reason you don't
feel like praying you still worship
Allah
it's better than oh after 30 years I've
spontaneously finally feel like praying
because I I really like the Lamborghini
I saw now I want to be rich
and to be fair my my point just now was
just as reductionist at this point but I
did that on purpose because it's not
fair it's not fair to make such a
reductionist point on prayer in one
religion
so honestly I don't even really want to
entertain this part anymore I think
maybe we can run to the next one unless
five unless you have something jumping
on no that's it bro
okay
I look forward to this bro because I
remember when the third Muslim
will start the unho that the chat can't
see right now on this stream when he
accepted his son it was one of the
happiest days of my life alhamdulillah
and the very next day if not a few days
later I see a video from April I mean a
red one almost from red one
uh saying Muslim River Deconstructed on
her something like that he made like a a
response video to unho really yes and
and I remember like everyone was so
happy bro all of Angel Subs even the
non-muslims were so happy from and he
made this pathetic video I think I saw
like a minute of it I couldn't even sit
through the whole thing it was like a 30
or 40 minute video off of Angelo's like
10 minute revert video and I was like
subhanallah man and since then he's made
a lot of responses or at least people
have mentioned that he addressed things
that we've said or videos that we've
made but we've never had a face to face
we've never had the privilege or
pleasure of having a civil mature
professional discussion with him so I am
very much looking forward to that
inshallah
inshallah inshallah 100 percent
relationship secondly when it comes to
talking about hierarchies it really
depends on what he means when he says
that now I'm not a Catholic so I won't
speak to that but the answer but there
you go you should speak to that because
there are direct hierarchies and
Catholicism the pope is like the
political leader of a religion what
about the Bishops what about the priests
this is another problem with
Christianity
this is so stupid
I mean has he never heard of the
caliphates has he never heard of uh of
something like the California the Imam
this is a I I guess he hasn't he is not
very well informed he's not very very
smart not very well read but it is it is
known in Islamic history universally and
even if you look into the Hadith it is
known that Muslims are Muslims are
supposed to have a leader who is there
who is appointed who is given and
appointed by Allah and that's how he
becomes the leader and Muhammad in the
Hadith which are attributed to him which
are questionable says that Muslims are
to obey their leader no matter what
unless the leader uh commands them to
explicitly to go against their religion
and encourage us uh harm and encourages
um on Islamic
um Blasphemous Haram things but this is
very well known and throughout Islamic
history Muslims had the uh the the
caliphate a caliph who was literally the
political and spiritual leader of Islam
I think exactly what he just said
and uh and notice you also have things
like profits and so on as part of the
hierarchy but but this this is another
problem with him not understanding any
point John is making he's saying John is
saying I can't speak for for for a
hierarchy in the Catholic church then he
says oh but you should speak up because
they've got a hierarchy
I mean why listen bro Catholicism is
literally half of Christianity half of
Christians are Catholics
an entire Empire was built on this
two empires actually if you look at um
the Eastern Orthodox Church as well
all of Europe so yeah it does need to be
addressed even if if John is not uh a
Catholic all he has to say is that's a
problem with Catholicism I don't believe
in that move on okay
moving on like he does have to address
it what they said about Islam is true by
the way you know that we have a
hierarchy in in in a term 100 but there
is a deeper issue with hierarchy and if
it's legitimate or not and what it
entails and what it shouldn't entail
inshallah I'll let them finish because
there's more to the clip and then I'll
respond isn't the one who said he had
problem with the hierarchy you are right
you said
John isn't saying I have a hierarchy so
John isn't saying oh I've got a problem
with the hierarchy and sneakers well
they need to respond to the Catholic
Church John isn't saying that sneako
said I reject Catholicism because of the
hierarchy and I let Islam better because
there's no hierarchy and then
it's like oh oh go ahead no go ahead go
ahead go ahead and finish it it's like I
was just thinking well I mean I mean I
thought about this too but I didn't put
in there but if we're all guys shows in
a raw equal and then you have Muhammad
is Muhammad that we're in this hierarchy
either right like yeah I don't know it
doesn't it doesn't make a ton of sense
to me yeah I mean
that's why I was trying to say in the
video it's like depending on what he
means by hierarchy because it otherwise
I can't understand why he would say what
he's saying it doesn't make sense to me
I I know why you would say it because he
has no clue what he's talking about
that's true he doesn't even know what
he's saying zero clue what he's talking
about and no but I mean notice notice
how weird this is right
everything he's saying as a reason for
rejecting Christianity and accepting
Islam actually is a problem for Islam
and he doesn't know it you're pointing
out you're pointing out what's he what
does he keep doing he'll say he'll say I
have a problem with submitting to a man
and you say but you're required to
submit submit to Muhammad in the in this
religion so oh no no but you know pray
to him actually
it's funny how one obviously I already
repeated this until he's again
misquoting him
um but I think this is all boring
there's one more Point like you just man
up and like you just say okay well I was
wrong I have to think this over more
before I decide that this is actually
what I'm going to race I mean yeah so
we'll see what happens but that is
actually what happens uh quite a lot but
with people who convert to Islam um
without understanding it fully they
later find out that uh that there are a
lot of problems with Islam and that
there are a lot of problems with the
things that they thought about Islam but
then at that point it's already too late
because they already convinced
themselves that Islam is true and they
already propagated it to others and told
us that they couldn't start this sad
reductionist argument look at how many
reverts we have that are just so
steadfast on the dean preaching Islam in
such beautiful ways and you're just
going to reduce all them to oh look at
how many people regret but it's just
it's too late
it's just too late that's very sad
convert it so it's already too late to
just say oh okay you know
yeah and that that seems to be these the
strategy in dala it's spout say whatever
you need to say in order to get this
person to convert it's so funny that's
exactly what they do that is literally
exactly the same parented stuff that's
been refuted over and over that he's
mentioned even in this video again that
has been refuted not just by us but by
other people by other people previously
and they're just parroting the same
stuff it's so funny that's so
hypocritical
then once the person has converted based
on these completely absurd reasons that
you made up then get him completely
embedded in the Muslim Community
especially if it's a woman if she's the
one immediately get her married and
pregnant what instantly like as quickly
who's who's promoting this stuff what
the heck is he talking about man
I swear these people just sometimes they
just make things up bro what the heck is
that
please you can't get this woman married
and pregnant because it is much more
difficult for a woman who now has
children and a Muslim husband and a
Muslim Community to then say Oh I'm
rejecting Islam now it like splits up
the family splits up you know it messes
it messes up her life a lot the goal is
get them in by any means necessary and
then this is the Bishops what about the
priests see this another problem with
Christianity is they can never decide
what the [__] is Christianity Who
belongs and who doesn't none of them
even
kidding me man that is so insanely
stupid yeah go ahead well I was just
saying he's under the impression there
no Muslims disagree but I mean he gets
the clip a while back up there she's
like well there's not a difference I'm
sorry that is not a straw man I'm gonna
stop the clip because I'm waiting for
them to get to a point but I just I
don't know when it's coming
um this is another example of missing
the forest for the tree so they're
nitpicking small things and yeah 100 he
seems to have misunderstood there's some
kind of authoritarian or not Authority
and that has a bad connotation but some
kind of authority and hierarchy and all
that stuff political structure
in Islam but the problem with the kind
of I'm going to stick with the Catholic
and the Eastern Orthodox hierarchy as
it's completely illegitimate literally
completely illegitimate
who was the pope why does he have this
Divine divine right why did they create
the divine right of kings this is
exactly why Martin Luther not Martin
Luther King no not the political rights
activist
but Martin Luther the German priest who
lived in the 1500s he went against the
church
because he he they the church were
basically letting people pay money to
the church so they can be forgiven
I forgot what it's called it starts with
an i
indulgences that's what it is they would
pay indulgences they would pay the
church
to forgive their sins
where is this in the Bible Martin Luther
read it and he's read other things in
saw this has literally nothing to do
with Christianity and he denounced it
and he was a pivotal point a pivotal
person
and getting the the masses to move away
from the divine right of kings and the
church and churchianity and so on and so
forth some Sam's asking who is Martin
Luther maybe they don't know what uh the
protectionism you want to go into that
yeah Martin Luther is a German uh
no he's not related to Martin Luther
King no he's not Martin Luther lived in
the 1500s and he was like I mentioned a
German priest
and he read the Bible and he found that
there was nothing of indulgences paying
for your sins to be forgiven that the
the the the church was preaching there
was nothing about divine right of kings
they completely made that up and he
denounced it and he moved away from it
this is the problem with the hierarchy
because they get and this is what sneako
is saying or what appears to be
um this appears to be what he's saying
that every single point in turn you're
changing something else first they were
subordinationists let me get in the
camera then you had modalism uh then you
had separationism then you had this ISM
not ISM and these are all different
understandings of who God is by the way
is he one person with two different uh
two different uh um is he like is he
basically a two-in-one person
you know that's what separationism is
the two separate person kind of coming
into one is he um is the father greater
than the Son and the son greater than
the Holy Spirit are they all co-equal
Quote Eternal it took 300 years
300 plus years to decide that the
father-son Holy Spirit are co-equal
Eternal it took till the 15th century as
Dr Ali atai mentioned on the stream I
did with him check it out by the way
took 50 to the 15th century
right which this was after Islam by the
way right
like over a thousand years
to fully canonize the Bible 100 fully
canonize it
so yeah it is changing the scripture the
beliefs the practices the laws they're
100 are changing and compare it to in
Islam
they don't have anything they don't have
like
um they don't have like
um
or um any like maksad or sorry they
don't have any like any any real general
principles or any actual uh rulings to
go based off of they don't have any they
don't even have reliable sources on what
Jesus said or didn't say or how he lived
how he didn't live
so of course they're not going to have
proper law and they're going to have to
make it up as they go
and that's what we saw happen I mean
historically speaking and silk has never
been changed or altered at all the
methodology of film today of course as
time goes on we're gonna have new things
coming up new technologies new just
people will use novel things that are
invented or innovated or whatever that
weren't there 1400 years ago so we need
fatawa from Scholars we need rulings by
Scholars but the ways that they come to
these fatwas to these rulings are the
same the methodology doesn't change at
all this is unique to Islam no other
religion has this yeah there's literally
a Hadith where the process he was going
to send two people to be judges in Yemen
two companions and he asked one of them
how are you going to rule he asked them
how are you going to rule how are you
going to make laws how are you going to
come to decisions how are you going to
judge between people
the sahabi the companion said I will
refer to the Quran
and the Sunnah and if I can't find the
answer there I will take a known the
known issue something that's known and
compare it to the unknown issue
for example we now have phones we can
get Quran on our phone the text of the
Quran that's my cat by the way we can
get the text of the Quran on our phone
is that like the text of the Quran in a
book so can I not take my phone with
Quran on it to the bathroom just like I
can't take the physical book to the
bathroom
they compare the like issues and come to
a conclusion same thing with alcohol and
weed they compare the like issues that
it it's some kind of that it intoxicates
you in some way it hinders your mental
mental capacity in a significant way and
they do what's called chaos analogical
deduction
and liking the ruling to that that's how
specific the rulings in Islam are you
don't have any deal I'm sorry you don't
have anything like this in the Bible
nothing that's why there's so much
subjectivism in what you can and can't
do except for the big things like
coveting thy neighbor's wife and the
things that are clear if you don't have
anything for like new issues now where
does I'd love to see where Jesus talks
about you know
um weed in the Bible or something like
that it's something that you can liken
to weed unless there's some way to
deduce that wheat it's like alcohol and
the way that the Muslims did it but then
I would accuse you of copying this down
and the most difficult thing
it's heavy on the heart bro is to come
to the realization that we don't know
what is preserved in the Bible and what
is not yes we can find things that align
with Islam and yes we can find things
that don't align with Islam but because
of this a lot of people look at and a
lot of Muslims they say oh Islam you
know said this in the Bible how do you
know
we can't use this as an objective gold
standard of Truth can we
yeah yeah it's a great point that is a
great point
and now I don't want I don't want I
don't want brothers and sisters to fall
into the issue of picking and choosing
things from the Bible that sound like
they might be reliable to us because we
know that the Bible has been changed so
even things that you as a Layman might
look at all of us as laymen might look
at and say that oh you know what this
sounds like something he said and then
you use it in arguments with Christians
or against Christians that's not the
best tactic because fundamentally we
believe that the Bible has been changed
absolutely 100 percent
and um I think that is that is a really
big point for for John and Christians to
answer and I think it's very rarely
discussed you know why do you affirm the
Bible is true why do you read every
single passage as if Jesus 100 said it
especially when you have passages that
are very clearly later Editions
um like the last ball versus The Mark
like first John 5 3 I believe and many
other ones but and we're actually
dropping a podcast tomorrow are we bro
that you had with the New Testament
scholar do you want to talk about that
yeah yeah so um I spoke with Dr Dennis
McDonald here in um in California
he's a new testament scholar and he's
kind of uncovered a new kind of
criticism of the Bible which he calls
literary Nemesis which is essentially
the people who wrote the Bible
talk stories of like epic people from
the past like like Homer and Odysseus
they took stories of them and they
basically replaced them with Jesus and
said Jesus did this or they replaced
Paul with uh the main person and said
Paul did this this happened to Paul and
this is so clearly in the New Testament
time and time again he's written like an
encyclopedia on it basically
um I think there's
the book is titled um
uh tragedy uh something epic tragedy and
Homer or something like that the gospels
of Epic tragedy and Homer I think that's
what it is and let me just give you one
example there's a play called the bakai
by euripides and it it was like it was
written like three four hundred years
before Jesus and it says
that Dionysus is a god of two of two
natures and his nature is that of a like
a dual nature
and it's going to be up tomorrow by the
way inshallah for the person asking the
podcast so Dionysus is a son is the son
of Zeus an immortal woman right like the
Son of God basically and a mortal woman
okay
and
he's the god of wine and he can produce
wine for people to drink and basically
they'll be absolved of their issues and
problems okay and he's of a dual nature
like a man and God nature
literally that is Dionysus and this
person in the play appears to someone
who is persecuting the Believers of him
and says to him
why do you kick against the goads
which is basically saying like why are
you wasting your time and if you look at
the uh the the book in the New Testament
Acts
you see that it's written about Paul
that he was persecuting the believer
Believers of Jesus
who was basically man and God dual
nature the Son of God and a woman okay
God and Mother Mary
and came basically appeared to him on on
while he's persecuting and said the
words why do you kick against the goads
literally same exact plot Point same
exact line
400 years before Jesus and then
apparently it happened to Paul
and that exists many times over for
Odysseus and Homer and other epics from
the past so I know that was a lot it
might have been boring for some of you
but it's something that needs to be
investigated for the Bible and it's this
is something just watch the podcast
tomorrow it's going to drop inshallah
and you wonder why the oldest
manuscripts you have of the Bible are in
Greek and not Aramaic the language that
Jesus spoke yeah listen these were great
they're not only Greek they were trained
scribesmen most people couldn't read or
write and if they could very rarely
could they read and write so eloquently
like you find in the Gospels
how many of the Disciples of Jesus could
actually read and write
how many of them maybe one or two maybe
a few
the fishermen could not read or write
so
there's a lot there and a lot to
investigate but the principles the Bible
is true and then go based off that
um is not fair academically and it's not
fair intellectually
um there's one more clip I did want to
bring it up
um oh I need to share my screen
go I'm as the most uh red pilled
religion so oh my god with the super
chats the superb tree we have refuted
red pill uh many many times so let me
see if he's using it in the in the
popular meaning of red pill which is
this uh manosphere movement I do want to
see unless he's just talking about it
like unlock their walk to reality yeah
AP Dave and John that's true but I just
want to put that up because uh that's a
picture of Sophie I don't think he
elaborates on it AP when you were in uh
when you were living in Germany did you
see like schools called Sophie Scholl
school or something maybe I heard it's
like a common it became a company for
anyone who doesn't know she was she was
part of a group that uh posted some
newsletters called The White Rose they
were she was sentenced to death for
opposing Hitler for uh encouraging
resistance against Hitler yeah she was
an anti-nazi yeah who by the way used
the Bible to justify what he did but
anyways this is virtually identical to
the Christian position although there
will be levels like for example the the
Imam or the Sheikh will have a certain
level not over people in sight of God
but we listen to them because they have
knowledge people like the leader of the
Islamic community we listen to them
because they're they're the leader they
were kind of put in place by God to make
sure look
we have to listen to them because
they're the leader put in place by God
okay are you the leader put in place by
God no so you have to submit to the
leader put in place by God uh-huh is
that a hierarchy yeah should this be a
problem for snico yes given what he just
said but nothing matters nothing seems
to matter to him
Community safe and they have
responsibility just like a husband has
responsibility for his wife and kids
there's a level of of authority there
level better a level of authority what
do you call a level of authority
[Music]
I think there's a word for levels of
authority
creation
yeah is it creation is that the level
that's the thing this guy is cool and uh
kind of dumb but these these two guys
they actually they they know exactly
that they are not they know they are
dishonest because
it's so funny it's so funny that he came
and he commented he was like speak to me
not in my place and it's like yeah I'm
just I'm I'm being dishonest what did I
lie about and what do we say did I not
did I not just say
did I not just say that for a lack of
better word there is there is a
hierarchy there is Authority
and then try and draw a comparison
between or a differentiate between the
authority and Islam and the authority in
Catholicism
which by the way everything I said
before that's exactly what I was
thinking of I'm like okay sneakers
referring to
um you know like the divine right of
kings and all this stuff in European
history that's generally what I thought
so that's why I explained listen this
person
is put in place by God I should have
added I don't know what I do I should
have added this person's voted by the
Muslims and that's it's a right upon the
Muslims to vote for their leader to go
in place not that they're just given a
divine right and that's it but it's the
right of the Muslims to be basically
that to elect a leader and once they're
elected then basically you know Allah
has allowed them that authority to be in
place but it's not like
you know whoever has the power can just
seize it or whatever
um but so why why what did we lie about
that's what I don't understand he's so
he doesn't know us he doesn't know who
we are but apparently all Muslim dies
are liars just because they're I don't
know and I'm still confused on what I
lied about but regardless let's continue
I'm just trying to they're trying to do
damage control
uh you know they attempt to become a
disgruntled new Muslim so they want to I
wouldn't say the dishonest I'd say that
they're just trying to they're trying to
do damage control while trying not to
shut them publicly so I kind of I I
mean I I honestly feel bad for them in
that position because this would be
awkward right all the reasons that he's
given you for why he rejects
Christianity you know apply to Islam
like we're supposed to do in that sense
you can either call them out and then
like you know demotivate them and then
basically like you know what I mean kick
them out of Islam once he realizes what
he did and then they don't want that
because you know what I mean they think
it's the truth so so I don't
particularly see this dishonest I mean
people get disagreement I think I think
it's Noble that you are so charitable uh
yes but they wouldn't be remotely as
forgiving as if they respond to you I
know these people and yeah oh
okay red one knows us apparently he
knows what do you mean by these people
uh what do you mean these people
apparently he knows these people he
knows exactly Who We Are
and that we're just willing to lie or
something like that I I really respect
the um
uh how genuine John is and how fair he
is being although I disagree with him
and I think that there were big points
that were missing I think he
misunderstands them very clearly
um it's very I think sad that he teamed
up with red Von and David wood for this
out of all people I think that he could
have taken a much
um more intellectual approach instead of
just you know sit with two people just
laughing and joking the whole time
essentially but
yeah I mean like I mentioned there is a
huge discrepancy between what we have in
Islam for leadership and what you had in
like the the Western and Eastern
churches in Europe I one into it I'm not
going to go into it again but Allah if I
take the super challenge
so brother Khaled asked how do I sign up
to help I'll discuss topics mod Etc
inshallah bro just send us a DM at the
three Muslims one word just like you see
the YouTube channel typed out under you
aside from that you can DM us
individually my Instagram or Romney's
Instagram all the links in the
description that you need to know if
you're in our Discord community
big Community it's popping their
aluminatic you can get on that
communicate with us there too or if
you're part of the Oma Academy you can
communicate with us there too many ways
to reach out to us more ways to reach
out to us than not to reach out to us so
inshallah it will be very easy we check
through DMs very regularly if not at the
T3 M1 then definitely our personal ones
inshallah Rami can definitely reply to
you if you reach out inshallah
putting the work on me
yes sir bro I was just playing I'm just
playing but um yeah initially I was
going to play a clip from Red Von
now I'm gonna let it be inshallah
I'm gonna let it be inshallah the reason
is because I think
he was fairly respectful in the comments
and I appreciate that
so I will not play the clip I will not
go any deeper in that
and I'll let him be I think it's fair
just to leave it at that clip and why
not you know obviously they're very
Incorrect and they're um analysis of
Islam I don't want to say of what snakeo
said because what he said was ambiguous
I think there are some things that are
very clearly implied or that you can
clearly uh you know imply with what he
said
um that they missed for some reason but
um call us at the end of the day this
was just meant to clear some
misconceptions and be completely honest
about the truth of Islam and not lie or
sugarcoat anything despite what some
people might Claim about us
this is Sonia wrote uh this comment
uh you strike me as a thinly veiled new
atheist a person or a ravenous to tear
into any kind of religious claims but
disgusting in terms of just being
rationally seeking truth and then buddy
wrote quite wrong I mean listen at the
end of the day
um if you I would sorry go on no no I
was just gonna say bro like
all petty comments you know aside and
all these personal things aside
we generally are open to having a
conversation with you and this can be
at a proper time that works with all of
us there's no point going back and forth
even listen
stuff happened with young Don last year
we get it right A lot of people have
been commenting about this but listen
Allah is all forgiving and at the end of
the day we as Muslims are not
Gatekeepers to hidayah I don't know why
a lot of Muslims are moving like oh how
can how can this person say this and
then come back to Islam bro are you an
Arbiter of who gets hidayah and not what
made you the the person that's kind of
like the the person guarding the bridge
to guidance from Allah you're not you're
you yourself are a fallible human being
that should be grateful that you got
hidayah from Allah so no matter all you
know what sins people have done how much
they've slandered Islam if they make
tawba since your troba and they turn
back to Allah then we are nobody to turn
them away from Islam so with yangdan we
have an intention of generally talking
to him about Islam he has been on our
stream in the chat I think last week
when Nami was doing with Dr aliyatai and
he said he'll plan it with us despite
everything that that has happened so my
sincere invitation to ridwan is bro it's
not too late and maybe a part of you
will genuinely Vibe with what I'm saying
right now I get it you're getting paid
there's a huge burden that you carry on
your shoulders for you to continue
operating maybe financially maybe with
the clout that you are operating at
right now continuing spewing misguidance
but I guarantee you
even if it's a tiny part of you deep
inside you agree that perhaps you might
be wrong about everything
and that this arrogance that you carry
thinking that you're right about all
this nonsense that you've been refuted
at multiple times
what's the point of that bro
maybe David wood I'm not gonna make a
personal thing right but he's been well
isn't there a documentary showing that
he wanted to off his dad with a hammer
so I can't I can't necessarily gauge his
sanity
but red one has never proved otherwise
sure he ate a Quran or whatever or or
you know whatever that's that's in the
past right but you've never given me any
reason thus far to judge your sanity
your sound state of mind so if you want
to have a conversation with us inshallah
we will arrange it just like young Don
bro there's nothing that you will do
that will shut us off from a
conversation as of yet
isn't that right bro
foreign
yeah I guess so personally I mean uh he
left a very respectful comment here and
I want to acknowledge that he says the
three Muslims by comments were not
appropriate I acknowledge that again I
prefer talking instead of prejudice and
I appreciate that very much I I do as
well
um you know all of us all three of us on
Hills don't hear about three of us do as
well so I do appreciate that I think
that it's very respectful and um you
know if we have ever said anything
disrespectful we ask that you forgive us
we ask that Allah forgives us and um you
know we uh he didn't ask for forgiveness
but you know I forgive you for anything
that you said against uh against us
inshallah
with that being said I think she'll ever
go to end off the stream again watch out
for the stream tomorrow not the stream
bro what does this mean
fired eight
um it's uh it's a saying like you know
you did well basically
okay not with this uh lingo bro
it's okay I'm too old
all right everyone for joining me I love
bless you all investing insha Allah
um freed responds if he's not live now
we'll be live very soon so everyone go
my girl over to his channel inshaallah
and check out his stream and inshallah
check out the stream not the stream I
keep saying that the video the podcast
dropping tomorrow between me and Dr
Dennis McDonald discussing literary
Nemesis and the Integrity or lack
thereof of the New Testament now
now there's one more comment I want to
put up thanks I appreciate your attitude
and response likewise
I love that we put on hold on the
thumbnail with uh with the red one and
and wood but I know it's not even on it
yeah but but red one is
that being said may Allah bless you all
immensely
and I'll see you on the next one